foreign
gma's Amy robach and TJ Holmes getting
cozy during the holidays
check out the pair at the Atlanta
airport the day after Christmas
traveling together amid their romance
and the drama that's followed in the
headlines it's Friday Eve
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes yeah it's been quite a
holiday season for these two last month
news broke of Amy and TJ's relationship
which they previously kept on the down
low a source previously told ET it had
been going on in secret for quite some
time another source confirmed to E.T the
co-anchor separated from their spouses
over the summer keeping the romance
alive in any relationship well maybe
it's a challenge these days just a
little bit sometimes right TJ split from
his wife attorney merrily feebig after
getting married in 2010. and Amy she
broke things off with her husband actor
Andrew Shu also after 12 years of
marriage Andrew and I are in our second
marriage we have a blended family we
have step children it was not easy and
sometimes it still isn't easy news of
Amy and TJ's romance dominated the media
as a result an investigation was
launched to see if they violated any
company policies the investigation is
still ongoing and for the time being
they've been suspended on air welcome
everybody to what you need to know on
this Monday Amy Robuck and TJ Holmes
have the day off instead Stephanie Ramos
and Gio Benitez have stepped in I'm
Stephanie Ramos and I'm Gio Benitez we
are so glad you are here with us to
begin this brand new week here on gma3
as for when Amy and TJ's Rendezvous
began sources say it's truly unknown
adding they did their best to keep
things professional and private despite
a few friendly on-air exchanges we will
spare you America yeah viewers can't
help but go back and look at the footage
with new eyes isn't that your favorite
he always gets him in the holiday spirit
why do I tell you few things in
confidence another tip is to train with
friends you set the agenda you say
here's the report
but despite the Scandal a source
recently told ET they're trying to keep
a low profile and let the dust settle it
is working chaos though it all somehow
figures itself out on television but
behind the scenes yes it might seem like
a madhouse it's been a great week before
this one to keep going and going and
going just enjoy it
[Music]